security was traditionally considered an
afterthought in software developed it is
becoming an increasingly important
concern for all aspects of app
development from design to deployment
and beyond
the number of programs produced
distributed deployed and patched across
network continually increases
as a result application security
features must deal with a wide range of
risks
let's take an example
a malicious script may be mirrored on
the victim's web browser or kept in a
database and run whenever the user
contacts the proper function depending
on the kind of attack in question here
this allows malicious code to be entered
in the case of an output
the major cause of this attack is faulty
user input validation which allows
malicious input to enter the final
output
an evil user can enter a script that
will be injected into the website's code
the browser will then be unable to
determine whether the process code is
harmful
as a result a malicious script is
performed on the victim's browser or a
focus form is shown to the users
are you aware of which attack this is if
not
do stay till the end to find the correct
answer are you aware of which attack
this is
if not please stay to the end of the
video to know the correct answer
hey everyone welcome to today's video on
application security before we move
forward subscribe to our channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from us
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered today
we start by learning about application
security and its different types we
learn about the most common
vulnerabilities in abstract followed by
the importance of application security
in today's cyber security space
next we cover some attacks against
application layer security and end the
video with some protection techniques to
enforce application security parameters
so let's start by learning about
application security from a grassroots
perspective
application security which is often
known as appsx protects application
software from external security threats
by utilizing security software hardware
methodologies best practices and
different processes
organizations require application
security technologies that safeguard all
of their programs from internal to
popular external apps on consumer mobile
phones
these solutions must address the whole
development cycle and provide testing
after an application has been deployed
to detect possible issues
application security mechanisms are
capable of testing web pages for
possible and exploitable vulnerabilities
analyzing code and assisting in the
administration of development and safety
management processes
the testing solutions must also be
simple and easy to install for system
administrators worldwide
consumers utilize hundreds of
applications daily to access
theoretically important and favored
services such as e-commerce banking
music etc
to be productive these professionals use
a variety of software solutions as well
ranging from online word checkers to
tablet-based creative tools among other
things
back-end software of course exists to
automate essential operations and
processes and decreases human labor
but to make matters worse the quantity
and complexity of these apps and their
backend code is increasing
the software security problem 10 years
ago was about securing desktop apps and
static web pages that were natively
harmless and easy to scale through and
defend
because of outsourced development the
number of legacy programs and in-house
development that uses third-party open
source and commercialized off-the-shelf
software modules the software supply
chain has become considerably more
convoluted
now that we understand application
security on a general level let us go
through some of the different categories
or the types of application security
the three major types to be covered in
this section
web application security api security
and cloud native application security
a web application is a program available
to the internet and it operates on a web
server the client is accessed using a
web browser
the applications by definition must
allow connections from clients across
unsecured network
this exposes them to a variety of risks
many online apps are mission critical
and include sensitive customer data
making them an attractive target for
attackers and a top concern for any
cyber security program or framework
the advent of https which offers an
encrypted channel of communication
guards versus man in the middle attacks
or mitm attacks has addressed several
online application weaknesses
many weaknesses though still persist
many security providers have created
solutions specifically geared to
safeguard online applications in
response to the rising challenge of web
application security
a web application firewall is an example
of a security technology meant to
identify and prevent application layer
results in the case of web applications
when it comes to apis
apis that have security flaws at the
root of many major data breaches they
have the potential to reveal sensitive
data and disrupt vital corporate
processes
api security flaws include unsufficient
authentication unintended data
disclosure and a failure to apply rate
restriction which allows api abuse
the requirement for api security like
the necessity for web application
security has led to the creation of
sophisticated equipment that can
discover api vulnerabilities and protect
apis in production level
the third type is cloud native
application security
infrastructure and environments are
often built up automatically in cloud
native apps depending on declarative
configuration which is known as
infrastructure as score or iac
developers are tasked with developing
declarative settings and application
code both of which should be secure
because practically everything is
defined during the development stage
shifting left is even more crucial in
cloud native setups
traditional testing techniques can help
cloud native apps but they are
insufficient
dedicated cloud native security
solutions are mandatory at this point of
time which are capable of instrumenting
vessels container clusters and
serverless operations reporting on
security concerns and providing
developers with a quick feedback loop
now that you have covered the different
types of application security let us go
through some of the most common
vulnerabilities that these frameworks
face on a daily basis
first is cryptographic failure
when data is not adequately safeguarded
in transit and at rest cryptographic
failures which are formerly known as
sensitive data exposures
occur it has the potential to reveal
credentials health information credit
card details and personal information as
well depending on the type of data being
protected in that particular case
injection attacks citra attackers can
use injection vulnerabilities to convey
malicious information to a web
application interpreter it has the
potential to assemble and execute this
data on the server
sql injection is a popular type of
injection which i've already covered in
an introduction for this video
another major vulnerability are outdated
components
vulnerable and out of trade components
encompass any vulnerability caused by
obsolete or unmaintained software it can
happen if you construct or even use an
application without first learning about
its core components and versions
authentication failures
identification and authentication
failure which are previously known as
broken authentication encompass any
security issue involving user identities
identity attacks and exploitation may be
avoided by implementing secure session
administration authentication and
validation for all identities in the
organization
in the next section let us cover some of
the protection mechanisms employed by
cyber security firms and third-party
automated software to prevent the
application layer from being bombarded
with sql injections and other attacks
the first is a web application firewall
or waf
a web application firewall monitors and
filters http traffic between our web
application and the world wide web
web application firewall architecture
does not address all risks but it may be
used in conjunction with other defense
mechanisms it can be used to the
portfolio of security solutions to
provide a comprehensive defense against
diverse attack ropes
it is a protocol layer 7 protection in
the open systems interconnection or the
osi model paradigm
that helps define online application
against attacks such as cross-site
scripting cross-site fraud skip
injection and file infusion
unlike a proxy server which conceals the
identity of client computers by an
intermediary a wire functions as a
reverse proxy fielding the server from
exposure
it acts as a barrier in front of a web
application protecting it from the
internet the clients must pass through
the web application firewall before they
can access the application
the second is threat assessment
a list of sensitive assets to safeguard
will assist you in understanding the
threat to your firm and how to minimize
them
considering how a hacker can infiltrate
an application if existing security
protections are in place and whether
additional tools or defense capabilities
are required it's also crucial to keep
your security expectations in check
nothing is impenetrable even at the most
stringent security measures
it would be best if you were realistic
about what you believe your team can
handle in the long run when pushed too
aggressively safety regulations and
procedures might be disregarded remember
that safety is a lengthy and time taking
project that requires the collaboration
of other employees and sometimes even
your customers
the next topic is privilege management
limiting privileges is vital especially
for mission critical and sensitive
systems
the least privileged principle states
that access to programs and data should
be limited to those who require them
when they require them
for two reasons the least privilege
principle is absolutely critical
the first is that hackers may compromise
less privileged accounts and ensuring
they do not acquire access to highly
sensitive systems is critical
the second is that internal dangers are
equally harmful as external adversaries
if insiders go bad it's critical to
ensure they never have more power than
they need minimizing the harm that they
may be able to cause to the organization
that's the end for this video
hope you learned something new today
if you have any doubts or any issues
with the topic feel free to let us know
in the comment section below and we will
get back to you as soon as possible with
some solutions subscribe to our channel
for more informative videos like this
thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here